26 Republican Attorneys General signing
a letter demanding President Biden and
Alejandra mearis let Texas secure its
border quote what you should do is
simple enforce the law and protect the
border and despite some recent
suggestions that you should nationalize
control of the Texas National Guard as a
ruse we would like to remind you you
cannot do so without legal Authority
that you currently lack if you cannot
bring yourselves to enforce the law get
out of the way so Texas can but the
president continues to defend his
handling of this
situation tell all I can be give me the
power I've asked him the very day I let
it off give me the border control give
me the people give me the people the
judges give me the people can stop this
to take it work right Shan Reyes is the
Attorney General of Utah he co-authored
that letter and he joins us now attorney
general good morning to you so this was
coordinated effort between you and 25
other state AGS so tell us about this
letter and what the goal here
is 25 other state AGS and the
legislature of Arizona so 27 States
totally I think you read what we said to
the federal government by the way the
president's words ring very Hollow right
now the ones that you just played
because his administration and their FA
failed border policies have created this
nightmare it's an outrage and we wanted
to know that we support Texas is right
to protect itself and it's not just
about Texas because of the Biden
administration's policies every state
including our own states are border
states now and we are dealing with this
torrent of criminal activity whether
it's human trafficking organized retail
crime or billions of doses of illicit
drugs and those are just the ones that
we've been able to confiscate who knows
how many more are coming across and then
you add on top as you've alluded to
National Security vulnerabilities and
threats a humanitarian crisis and all of
this is laid at the the feet of Texas
which is trying mightily and I would say
valiantly to protect itself and protect
the rest of America AG Rus what's so
important about your letter is that it
breaks down a lot of the lies put out
there by Joe Biden and the Democrats
lies on the law what is the truth about
how far Texas can go under the US
Constitution to protect itself and quite
frankly our
country well there's there's two
articles I want to focus on article 4
section four of the United States
Constitution requires the federal
government the Biden Administration to
defend our borders and defend the states
against an invasion now then you look at
Article 1 Section 10 in particular
clause three it gives the states
especially if the federal government is
abdicating its role it gives the states
the right to protect themselves with
their Sovereign power this is something
that James Madison talked about uh and
the other Founders they use the example
of Virginia and the Commonwealth of an
Invasion by Smugglers and the proper
exercise of its power so we want to
clarify for America that Texas is well
within its rights and that we're going
to support Texas again this is a fight
for for all of America and thank
goodness Governor Abbott and the great
attorney general Ken Paxton Texas are
stepping up to protect all of our
citizens well attorney general just
moments ago we were reporting on this
group of illegal immigrants who attacked
a group of police officers in New York
City uh and they have already been
released on bail so like we were saying
this is a cross-section of so many
issues when it comes to bail policies
illegal immigration and crime what's
your reaction to
that yeah as I mentioned before let me
start again with the humanitarian
problems 85,000 children who are still
missing who were at one time in the
custody of HHS now DHS HHS say we can't
find them we don't know where they're at
they're resp sponsors at some point so
you think about that put that in context
now also think about this layered on top
of the criminal crisis is
169 of those arrested in a one-year
period from the fall of 2022 through
2023 169 are names on America's Terror
watch list so think again about all of
those that we haven't caught there at
the border and then layer on billions of
dollars worth of human trafficking
whether that's sex trafficking uh labor
trafficking organ harvesting and and
again the the cartels are having a
Heyday they're actually working together
and cooperating because there is no
resistance at the border understood keep
up the fight our country depends on it
AG Sean Reyes thank you sir I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis